[Music]
technology changes our lives in amazing
ways if we knew your we managed to come
up with something that makes our lives
even better
I'm Raoul from simply learned and these
the top 10 technologies that you should
look out for in 2018
number 10 they stood with this suit Wynn
uses a digital or a virtual model of
process product or a service to check
how well it doesn't do in life now this
is use where it's too expensive to
actually create a real-life model so say
you have to test the effectiveness of a
robot that performs a task or performs a
process you have to build a digital twin
of the model then the model is tested
with scenarios and use cases now some of
the industries that use this technology
are the oil and gas industry the
renewable energy industry and the
aviation industry now let's talk about
how this technology is making our lives
easier it helps reduce product effects
because when the product is released in
the real world it's already being
validated using statistical twin it also
saves a whole lot of time and money it
shortens the time of marketing now let's
see what the future of the digital
tintin technology could be companies
will be able to use the data they obtain
from their IIT connected devices to help
serve their customers better hence
improving the revenue the Seoul twins
would come of great use in data
collection visualizing the data and then
analyzing it they would expand beyond
its current scope and integrate with the
wider set of technologies number nine a
PA or robotic process automation like
you've heard machines in manufacturing
plants that will perform their own
operations our PA uses a robot or a bot
to perform business processes that are
of high volume and to beat themselves so
RPI uses artificial intelligence and
machine learning together to handle jobs
that would be themselves some of the
tools that enable our PA blue prism
uipath and automation anywhere now these
are all software platforms they provide
the user tools to perform a PA on the
processes that they require now let's
talk about how our PA is used today
customer support a job like responding
to customers through chat can be
automated so that only the more complex
issues can come forward to the human
workers of Menten human capability by
reducing the effort humans put into a
redundant process a PA helps increase
the output of human beings by them
working on something else a whole chunk
of errors can be avoided by room
some of the human continents in the work
because unlike us a computer doesn't
tire nor does it take breaks so what's
in store for the future of our PA our PA
would grow into more different sectors
expanding from the current fields it
occupies so that several components of
the system coordinate and work together
the systems would move from a more rural
based system to ones that integrate AI
the system should be able to handle
unexpected situations on their own
number eight the Internet of Things the
Internet of Things interconnects several
physical devices home appliances and
just about all newly released electronic
devices that can exchange data over the
Internet
some of the more popular developer tools
using which IOT can be implemented are
the Arduino Eclipse and IBM Watson now
let's talk about how IOT is making our
lives easier companies are able to track
and analyze the data that the products
send back to them so that they can
provide their customers with an improved
experience wearables like the Fitbit
throw either users with a whole lot of
information from the number of steps
they take their shadows to notifications
from third-party apps total collection
stores a large amount of data from the
user for the companies to use now let's
see what the future of IOT has to offer
smarter cities the city officials can
monitor what is happening in the city
how the city is evolving and how to
enable a better quality of life to its
citizens routers will have to become
more secure to provide increased privacy
travelers will be forced to become more
efficient and secure we would also see
an increase in the usage of products
that use artificial then it's this would
make the users life a lot easier
number 17 DevOps DevOps brings together
tasks between teams so that they can
communicate and coordinate better with
each other this would increase
productivity in the process so the teams
I mentioned there the application
development team and the system
operations together they form a more
agile approach to software development
some devups tools that are quite
commonly used by companies are Jenkins
docker and chef these tools enable these
corporations to integrate the properties
of DevOps into different things so let's
talk about why devups is so important
now it reduces the amount of time it
takes for a product to be developed
built and tested this ensures the
customer receives the product faster the
output that the customer obtains is also
of higher quality it also assists in
disaster recovery it can help the car
the files faster so what's the future of
DevOps
although DevOps is a practice that is
seen in larger companies the future
would see the adopted to smaller
companies and teams so they can do takes
created successes integrating their webs
with Big Data projects would remove
major bottlenecks that sudden changes to
the nautical model would cause there
will also be an improved security to the
core in application as the product isn't
worked on by the apps team and the
system separately number six cyber
security cyber security involves many
technologies processes and practices
which ensure the data computers and
networks are protected from attack
damage and illegal access it provides
application security protects your
information your network and your
operations some of the more commonly
found cyber security tools are po sec
open vs onion lettuce bright and
Wireshark case of cyber security is
making our lives easier it prevents
spyware or any sort of other malware
from entering your system it prevents
the user from being attacked by adware
as well now adware although sometimes
innocent and unknowing could also spread
harmful viruses into the system cyber
security also ensures that the users
privacy remains intact so what's the
future of cyber security although
there's been significant steps being
taken to increase cyber security there's
still a lot more work to be done the
future would see more organizations come
together to provide a better defense
like inside the crack systems at some
point you'll be able to predict and even
combat new attacks AI integrated into
cyber security would ensure greater
protection after learning from
experience I think I'll just go and
change my facebook password it doesn't
have to be safe number five what should
reality and augmented react
what should reality uses computer
technology to create 3d environments
that users can interact and can be
mastered so here's an idea what a VR
experience would be like it pushes the
envelope of how much immersion the user
can have augmented reality integrates
the users environment and digital
information in real time
Pokemon Co is an example of one sets
experience AR would also be used in maps
and supermarkets providing essential
informations and generally making the
users life a lot easier they are all
gaming to be more immersive and personal
experiences flowing you to feel like
you're actively participating in the
events of the game there's also more
marketing that can be done with 3d and
animated catalogs flyers and brochures
Tazo helps victims rehabilitate after
they've gone through some trauma or
injury so what's the future of the our
Nayar education would be a more
immersive experience because a lot more
can be learned by seeing something
rather than hearing how it work
attractions and theme parks would be
more interesting and varied medical
students would be trained to perform
surgeries and other procedures giving
in experience very close to the real
thing number four big data big data is a
trend that extends across many
businesses and technologies it haves
organizations describe large and complex
data that cannot be handled by
traditional software that handles data
complex data using big data can be
visualized analyzed and stored some of
the open source tools that are commonly
used are a Patti spark talent and Hadoop
some data visualization tools a tableau
and power bi and data extraction tools
like Pass hub and Melinda so how is big
data making our lives easier you're able
to identify business risks much in
advance so that appropriate steps can be
taken it allows unstructured data to be
converted into data that can be used to
provide insights into how a company's
management works by extension it also
helps how well the company operates and
how well its products do so what's the
future of big data the future would
bring more ways to analyze data the view
more specific role of chief data officer
that overlooks how well the big data is
utilized big data is still relatively
less use the future would see more
companies rely on data to generate
revenue number three cloud computing
cloud computing uses a network of remote
service that are on the internet these
help store manage and process data
instead of actually using a personal
computer or server some of the more
commonly used service providers of cloud
computing are the AWS of the Amazon Web
Services Microsoft Azure and Google
cloud so how is cloud computing being
used right now it helps in backing up
and storage a file it coordinates with
big data analysis like customer behavior
buying patterns and so on to serve its
users better it provides infrastructure
as a service platform as a service and
backup as a service
what could cloud computing do in the
future there would be a wider variety of
applications that the cloud can provide
hybrid cloud which is an up-and-coming
technology would seem more mainstream
usage they would also be greater
innovation in the cloud considering how
fast technology is transforming
number two blockchain blockchain is a
continuous growing list of records
blocks these are secured and linked
using cryptography now some set of
records that block chains can use a
transaction details location of crypto
currencies and the users medical data so
you see here the records to form any
chain that keeps on building now here
are some types of crypto currencies some
of these you might have heard of and
some you raining for the first time this
Bitcoin like on it
triple Zed cache and - so how does lock
shake make our lives easier provides
increased capacity it also provides
better security against data being
stolen or being misused with all the
data available in one convenient
location transactions can also take
place at a faster pace now let's look at
the future of blockchain it might be
adopted by banks around the world
cryptocurrency would also be widely used
by people people will be able to move
past the initial fear of them and accept
it as another method of transaction it
might also give rise to new industries
and job opportunities and now we have
some special inventions now these are
technologies that didn't quite make the
curve that's not to say they are in the
bottom this is gathering steam over time
first we have quantum computing this
uses quantum mechanics to process and
store information adapter security which
is a dynamic approach to cybersecurity
it allows us based decisions to be taken
with an adaptive response under this NLP
which allows computers to interact with
human beings their language they can
understand and a number one we have
artificial intelligence and machine
learning artificial intelligence creates
intelligent computer systems that act
and think like human beings so here are
some AI tools that are commonly used
this prediction i/o which allows
developers and data scientists to create
their own predictive engines this is the
SEO machine learning workbench that
allows developers to build their own AI
agents or build upon existing models and
finally there's tensorflow it's a
software library that's used for
dataflow programming it's commonly used
in deep learning
now machine learning systems learn and
improve based on experience without
being programmed to actually do
something here the machine performs the
task learns from that task and improves
its performance for the next time around
so how is AI helping us now systems are
able to understand what the users are
saying to them and perform an action or
respond accordingly
smart cars that get better with
experience and virtual private
assistants like Alexa Cortana the
provide results based on user preference
how is machine learning helping us now
predicting the traffic conditions and
estimating what the taxi fares would be
recommending people to tagging images
and suggesting friends and social media
improving search results based on user
experience so in case you're wondering
machine learning is actually a subset of
AI so every example that is in ml also
comes under EA so what is the future for
AI and machine learning it might have
robot assistants to help in our
day-to-day activities like you see in
the movie I Robot cybernetic mV
Mintz might become a lifesaver for
accident victims or amputees
although automated transportation is a
thing that's being worked on right now
it's still a work in progress the future
would see a completely automated
transportation system maybe if you're
lucky we'll have our own robot uprising
now that you know the technologies that
you should be focusing on here's of
simply London he'll simply learn has
courses on AI and machine learning
cloud computing networking big data
business intelligence tools
cybersecurity blockchain programming
DevOps and data science so log on to
simply learn now to take your first
steps get certified and get ahead I hope
you guys enjoyed the video and found it
informative thank you and stay tuned for
more from simply done hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn YouTube channel and click here to
watch similar videos Turner DUP and get
certified click here